jean paul stahl infectiologues au chu de
grenoble allait pas bonjour et merci
d'être un an directeur avec montceau
arte france alors expliquez nous quelle
est la situation aujourd'hui chez vous
dans et autour de grenoble
la foire nous sommes nous allons
dépasser les solides alerte c'est bien
évidemment puisqu'il ya un peu plus de
autour de 40 % des lits de réanimation
et de soins intensifs qui sont occupés
par des patients atteints de la commune
et on a plus d'une centaine de patients
hospitalisés en médecine alors l'hôpital
n'est pas débordé pour l'instant c'est à
dire que l'hôpital est capable
d'absorber ces patients là est capable
de continuer à soigner les autres c'est
aussi ça qui est très important
aujourd'hui des malades
lukowich qui sont hospitalisés à dans
votre sachet mais les malades locaux
vides c'est ma foi c'est le panel tout à
fait habituelle de ce qu'on a l'habitude
de voir attend depuis depuis loin parce
c'est à dire le panel des sages le panel
des gravité c'est exactement comme la
dernière fois il n'y a pas de confiance
et leur comparer c'est seulement à cette
première vague au mois de mars notamment
est ce que vous vous sentez plus harley
aussi pour soigner ses patients au vu
des nouvelles connaissances que l'on a
sur dix ans alors on les soigne mieux ça
c'est vrai on les soigne mieux et en
conséquence il ya moins de passage en
d'animation proportionnellement parlant
ça c'est vrai et quand ils sont en
réanimation on a aussi appris à mieux
les mieux les traiter en particulier à
mieux les ventiler donc ça il ya on a
assisté à un vrai progrès ça c'est
absolument clair et puis deuxièmement en
terme d'organisation
c'est vrai que toute organisation y
compris la relation avec la médecine
libérale avec les cliniques et est
maintenant rodé et donc beaucoup plus
fluide que ce qu'elle a pu être au tout
début où on était en phase
d'apprentissage finalement
alors vous le dites les indicateurs
progressent aussi chez vous même si pour
l'instant la situation est sous contrôle
est-ce que vous vous sentez suffisamment
équipées dans votre siège pour affronter
la deuxième vague équipés en lits en
masquant gel en blouse en personnel
aussi évidemment oui je pense le je
crois qui a pas d'inquiétude de cet
ordre le haut niveau de l'hôpital la
vraie inquiétude c'est bien entendu un
afflux de patients qui perd qui devrait
faire reporter d'autres soins pour
d'autres cours d'autres patients mais en
ce qui concerne les patients
hospitalisés strictement parlant le
l'hôpital peut absolument faire face et
il est équipé de ce point de vue là on
n'a pas d'inquiétude mais ce qui va ce
qui va arriver c'est éventuellement le
le report ou l'annulation de soi pour
d'autres patients pour d'autres
pathologies
et ça c'est ça que d'avoir un impact
assez considérable est ce que le couvre
feu qui est en passe dans une dizaine
d'agglomérations derrière maximale est
ce que cette mesure qui est pointé du
doigt notamment pour ses conséquences
économiques en terme sanitaire est ce
qu'elle vous satisfait vous
l'infectiologue est ce que vous pensez
qu'elle contribue justement permettre de
maîtriser la situation en courant toutes
les mesures qui permettent une distance
où une barrière entre des individus dont
un d'entre eux est contaminateur sont
des bonnes mesures donc celle là est une
bonne mesure
c'est pas forcément la seule mais c'est
une bonne mesure le l'objectif c'est
d'éviter qu'à une personne contagieuse
transmettre à d'autres personnes
donc là c'est une bonne façon d'éviter
ces contacts permanents et quand
j'entends un certain nombre d'élus qui
hurlent parce que on va on empêche les
libertés et on empêche les gens de se
voir etc ce sont des irresponsables
il faut le dire clairement le
recommander le contact entre les humains
en ce moment et irresponsable même si on
peut regretter effectivement ce conseil
d'éloignement des individus mais c'est
comme ça c'est à ce prix là qu'on
évitera des morts si on ne fait rien
tous les modèles sont concordants là
dessus tous les modèles sérieux à
l'arrivée ce sera deux cent mille morts
en france est ce qu'on est prêt à payer
ce prix là on entend faire appel à la
prudence et à la vigilance merci
beaucoup jean paul stahl en fait cela au
chu de grenoble alpes